heure de chaque jour je vous demande
d'aller chercher les voix nécessaires à
l'état fait la victoire était un moment
extrêmement bouleversant que de
rencontrer des destins brisés
il ya le besoin de vérité qu'est ce qui
s'est passé
conclut par un appel à la responsabilité
je vois bien les candidatures qui se
multiplient mais comme vous j'ai pas
envie de revivre un 21 avril la commune
cents migrants
voilà la nouvelle association des maires
lancé aujourd'hui par steeve briois
c'était un vrai danger pour la france de
voir proliférer une multitude de petits
calais il le dit ni va trop fort en un
mot mais je pense que cette idée de
concentration même de concentration
répartis sur le territoire est une très
mauvaise idée
j'espère d'ailleurs que beaucoup de
maires quelle que soit leur étiquette
viendront rejoindre ce collectif pour
rappeler au gouvernement qu'il ne peut
pas mettre en oeuvre des mesures contre
la volonté du peuple français jacques
chirac est donc hospitalisé à la pitié
salpêtrière à paris l'ancien président
de la république âgé de 83 ans a été
admis ce matin pour une infection
pulmonaire
c'est un moment très émouvant que que
cet homme qui a connu les plus hautes
responsabilités soit dans le dénuement
comme ça de la maladie et de la
vieillesse j'espère de tout coeur que va
pouvoir se rétablit un passé c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup compté pour la
france et à titre personnel beaucoup
compté pour moi qu'un homme qui était
très sympathique et toujours très
attentif à la santé des autres à la
situation des autres je pense que les
uns ou les autres en tant que
journaliste mais aussi en tant qu'homme
politique de droite ou de gauche nous
savions cette attention qu'il avait
conquis la tohu individus et donc on
doit avoir la même attention pour lui
marque ce soir nous sommes des millions
de français avant une pensée pour lui a
souhaité qu'il se rétablisse le plus
vite possible
deux cent trente roses déposées deux
cent trente noms égrainé l'espace d'un
instant le temps s'arrête dans le jardin
des invalides
le premier ministre avec à ses côtés
l'ancien chef de l'état un écho la
sarkozie il faut mettre en place une
règle une réforme complète de notre
dispositif de lutte antiterroriste une
chaîne pénale complète puisque nicolas
parquet
savez-vous l'inspirait mais ça pour
l'inspirer j'inspire beaucoup pour
certains de nos compatriotes réclame
aussitôt des mesures qui vont affecter
les musulmans bien au delà de cette
frange sanguinaire ceux là sont
encouragées dans leurs peurs leurs
préjugés leur haine parfois par des
politiciens qui cherchent à récolter des
voix et des pseudos intellectuels qui
cherche à vendre des livres kosciusko
morizet et propose une loi
d'interdiction du salarié bien on croit
rêver
elle a proféré par conséquent une une
sottise je ne crois pas qu'il ait pu
imaginer qu'on pouvait fabriquer une loi
sur messala film et qui la contrôlera
une médaille pour les victimes du
terrorisme est-ce que ça a du sens
donnez-vous certaines familles
considèrent qu'au fond aucun merricks à
être être mort je pense que c'est un
sujet compliqué effectivement j'ai lu
des gens qu'ils y étaient sensibles et
d'autres qu'il prenait comme comme
quelque chose d'agressif avec gravité
vous nous avez exprimez ce que vous
attendiez de la nation bien plus qu'une
solidarité une fraternité une fraternité
parce qu'à travers vous c'est la france
toute entière qui a été visé par et je
voudrais d'abord que chacun ici puissent
avoir une pensée affectueuse pour le
président jacques chirac est hospitalisé
depuis dimanche entre ce qu'ils nous
racontent sur les musulmans se sur le
fait que ce serait une folie de recevoir
1800 réfugier dans une région de 8
millions d'habitants seulement évoqué
que cet homme et ses amis paieront très
cher le prix de leur cynisme sarkozy
faux lui marcher dessus
et du pied gauche sa porte monnaie c'est
vrai ce que je le chirac a dit
simplement monsieur derrière il l'a dit
il l'a dit
ah le moment où vous devenez français
vos ancêtres
ce sont les gaulois et c'est
vercingétorix
mon père est en droit on n'a pas appris
l'histoire la hongrie par une personne
qui vient d'un territoire étranger à la
france à d'autres ancêtres que les gros
doigts non résident les origines sont
plutôt franck et là encore je me répète
je suis pas convaincu que nos amis
martiniquais ou aux réunionnais se
retrouve totalement dans cette
définition la part au moment je suis
français j'aime la france
j'apprends l'histoire de france nation
simulation pardon je vais pas faire des
technologies ça veut dire que les tous
pareils et qu on devient tous trouvent
tous loi et qu'on coupe ses racines
quand on coupe les racines d'un arbre il
meurt on n'est pas tous pareils il faut
respecter notre diversité par thermo qui
ne me fait pas peur le mois simulation
simplement bien évidemment nos ancêtres
sont nos ancêtres ils ne sont pas tous
gaulois pourrait-il faire un cours
d'histoire à monsieur sarkozy
visiblement on a besoin oui il y en a
parmi nos ancêtres les gaulois il ya
aussi des roumains des normands des
celtes des burgondes nous sommes
français
nos ancêtres les gaulois un peu romain
un peu germain président alliant des
changes et sa vue au discours étriqué
qui ne nous mène nulle part
espagnole de plus en plus portugais
peut-être qui sait polonais et je me
demande si déjà nous ne sommes pas un
peu arabe et ça nous ramène à new york
où françois hollande a reçu hier le prix
de l'homme d'état de l'année un peu
insolite alors qu'il est au plus bas
dans les sondages en france
il reçoit ce prix je cite pour son
leadership dans la sauvegarde de la
démocratie et de la liberté en date de
ce jour là nous étions tous américains
today y aura mais aujourd'hui vous êtes
françois johann parce qu'on est
conscient que la menace parti socialiste
a lancé une offensive pour défendre le
bilan du quinquennat de françois
hollande
le message c'est le bilan est bon mais
les français ne le savent pas comment ça
se fait mais vous savez l'élection c'est
toujours l'occasion de se tourner vers
vers l'avenir je pense à lui avec
beaucoup d'affection je vous fais une
petite confidence j'ai fait un tweet là
dessus c'est le tweet où j'ai eu le plus
de j'aime ou de reprise de tout ce que
j'ai fait depuis que je twitte c'est
dire à quel point les français sont
attentifs à sa santé à quel point il
aime pour cette tragédie syrienne sera
devant l'histoire
une honte pour la communauté
internationale si nous limitons pas fin
rapidement
pour l'instant on ne bouge pas léger
sipa on bouge pas les occulter
mais jacques bourdin enfin jouer upa
mois à la tête des du culte musulman on
est d'accord montana il suffit dans
ladite les convois humanitaires sont
attaqués des armes chimiques sont
utilisés
eh bien je dis qu'un seul mot à dire ça
suffit que c'est surtout françois
hollande ça suffit parce que
l'impuissance de la france dans le
conflit syrien son impuissance sur la
scène européenne face au drame des
réfugiés
ces sacs dont j'ai envie de dire ça
suffit
nicolas sarkozy en visite à keller le
candidat à la primaire de la droite veut
mettre la crise des migrants au centre
de sa campagne et parler c'est une honte
c'est une honte pour la france
ces ballons sur les êtres humains vous
avez raison mais ce n'est pas parce
qu'ils sont malheureux
kimoce je regrette effectivement que
calais devienne un objet politique un
objet de campagne électorale parce qu'on
sait tous que dans les campagnes
électorales
en règle générale les mots dépassent
souvent la pensée et les mots ce n'est
pas souvent la réalité ce qu'on peut
faire marrer cette campagne
présidentielle ce s'ouvre sous de
mauvais auspices parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de la question sécuritaire
puisque du social évidemment évidemment
la liste des candidats à la primaire de
la droite et du centre est désormais
officielle
elle vient d'être rendue publique à
l'instant par la haute autorité chargée
d'étudier la validité des candidatures
par pas de suspense où vous concernant
rien c'est sûr mais nous et à petit
calais il ya une ou deux personnes qui
essayent de l'entretenir
qui sont les mêmes qui pendant six mois
on dit elle n'y arrivera pas là mais bon
chéri empêcher bon psychologiquement il
un problème avec le fait ça doit les
angoissés ils seront donc sept en tout
une femme et six hommes vous les
découvrez ici par ordre alphabétique
hervé mariton a été recalé n'a pas
rassemblé les 250 élus dont vingt
parlementaires aussi 13 parrainage qui
pose problème
alors si vous avez été posée mais vous
avez déposé 2520 pour vous dit
j'en ai 20 de marge mais si
effectivement sur les deux mille cinq
cent vingt années 90 qui soit n'ont pas
payé soit n'ont pas signé soit on soit
en doublon vous être juste marges et sur
le plan humain
une pensée pour hervé parce que
l'épreuve difficile à supporter à vivre
voilà donc je ne m'arrête je n'arrive
pas à me réjouir complètement de cette
nouvelle même si évidemment
politiquement ça ouvre un champ qui est
un peu nouveau pour moi dizaines
d'étudiants gabonais a fait irruption
dans la salle ils étaient venus dénoncer
le soutien à ali bongo de nicolas
sarkozy lorsqu'il était à l'elysée
petit patron qui prend des risques
quand j'ai entendu nos ancêtres les
gaulois comme on dit chez moi ça pue jeu
rien on fait jamais
nouaille
la campagne à droite est officiellement
lancée et certains des cinq candidats
retenus pour la primaire se montre déjà
très matinaux c'est donc à 6h34 qu'alain
juppé décide d'envoyer ce tweet très
lapidaire nullité du débat politique que
soulève certains à droite et à gauche on
débat des gaulois et si on parlait
d'avenir si vous voulez parler du gabon
retourner si vous êtes à l'aise avec ça
vous savez aujourd'hui on est devant une
france qui est extrêmement fracturée
avec des problèmes qui sont des
problèmes très importants notamment des
problèmes de migration ces sujets là
peuvent pas faire l'objet de tabou il
avec ni sur la table nicolas sarkozy a
choisi de rechercher le succès électoral
par la division du pays en obsédant les
français sur le l'origine sur les
gaulois sur l'identité sur les ans c'est
alain juppé paris bien une unité débat
politique ce matin bleu je crois que le
mot tu es juste part elle avait regretté
la nullité du débat politique sur
twitter très récemment
et je persiste le seuil et dominique
pour moi faire campagne c'est pas lâcher
une incongruité tous les jours pour
faire parler de soi vous lâcher je cite
une incongruité par jour je ne
polémiquerai pas ni avec juppé niais qui
que ce soit dire les autres sont nuls
c'est classique c'est ce que des à part
dont c'est ce que dit tout le monde et
ça ne fait pas avancer le débat je suis
certain qu alain avec les grandes
qualités qui sont les siennes vanu
redressa nous redresser ce à lui tout
seul je lui fais confiance
frais moi je souhaite que mon pays
fassent la démonstration il est capable
d'accueillir 9000
je ne parle pas d'un million je ne parle
pas de 100000 je ne parle pas de 50000
9000 réfugiés de calais nous n'aurions
pas nous la capacité d'accueillir dans
nos villes et dans le quartier ceux qui
demandent l'asile et qui fuient
aujourd'hui la guerre de la syrie ou en
irak
ça fait drôle